[Music]
[Applause]
he's been to eight final fours in his
career the other 15 coaches left in the
sweet 16 have a combined total of seven
final fours in other words coach Izzo
has been around a long long time I
thought I was able to outlast you know
all of these guys you know Coach K is
gone and Roy Williams is gone bayheim is
gone
and there you go you won't leave Tom
congratulations you've done it again
yeah like a bad habit man I'm still here
Dan but so are you so I guess we're in
this together yeah
um you know we shouldn't be surprised
but are you surprised that you're in the
sweet 16.
you know it's been a funny year I I uh I
like my team the whole year and that
doesn't normally happen uh you know we
had some a bunch of injuries early two
starters were out for quite a while and
uh as we started getting one of them
back I said you know this team we got
some experience uh we got some guys that
started playing well our guards uh you
know hogert and Tyson Walker and Jaden
Akins have really started to play well
together we started shooting it better
and uh so am I surprised not totally but
I thought the team we beat in Marquette
was a really good team really good
deserving where they were and where they
were seated
how do you coach in the tournament as
opposed to how you coached during the
regular season
well most of our fans think I golf
during the regular season and just kind
of sit back and do nothing and March
comes and I like start working or
something that is not true okay okay but
um you know I think one thing that we
talked about as a team we were a very
good defensive team early and we really
the last three weeks of the Season
didn't play very well at all and so we
kind of recommitted to that and realized
that uh not only at Michigan State but
in tournament play look at the teams
that were left Marquette great defensive
team like in our area now uh Kansas
State's good uh Tennessee's the the one
I think the best defensive team in the
country so uh defense still wins at this
time of year
you've got Kansas State coming up sweet
16 on Thursday the
um you know I started to look around
with bayheim he said he's felt relieved
to to step down like like there was just
weight off his shoulder he said it would
you know I had to get motivated to go to
practice uh Coach K probably went
through this
um you know bayheim talked about name
image and likeness like this has changed
um how how much has it changed though
let's say in the last 10 years for you
in coaching recruiting everything that
goes into this
well we've had segments 10 years ago it
really changed because that was the
birth of social media and Twitter and
and uh that really created problems for
coaches because not only do you take the
abuse but the players take the abuse and
then you have to help them navigate
through all the problems
and then you know five years ago four
years ago covet that affected everybody
but they're right you know I think Jay
writes in that group and he's younger
but does the uh nil and the transfer
policy has changed a lot of things and
not me personally none for the better
um and I think a lot of those guys felt
the same way and so I still love my job
I love going to work I love going to
practice I'm a little questioning my
profession right now I think a lot of
guys are and uh I don't know what that's
going to end up you know what do you
mean what do you mean you're questioning
you're perfect I don't like where the
profession is gone I I don't like the
rules the changes I don't think there's
anything good about
giving so much freedom to an 18 year old
that he can change jobs every hour on
the hour you know that's just my opinion
and I know that bothers some people
doesn't bother others but I I don't know
what people are going to do
that uh
they're unhappy one day they just leave
what are they gonna do when you get a
real job it might do the same
but uh you might have a family to feed
at that time so I think it's created a
problem Dan
of accountability and uh to be a real
good team there's got to be a some
accountability and uh it's getting a
little harder to do that but uh I'm
still hanging in there is there a
solution
well I think we let it get out of
control in the first place you know
maybe there was some solution I mean I'm
all for players getting some money but
I'm not all for players uh you know
where they say it can't be an enticement
and recruiting I mean who's kidding who
yeah uh I'm also not out for players
they're spending more time now on their
nil stuff than they are in their game so
they can make a little bit of money now
compared to becoming a pro and make a
lot of money so there's issues but uh
you know what I just play by the rules
that I'm given and try to do it the best
I can do in my way but I can't say that
it's made it easier in fact it's made it
more difficult it's made it harder to
coach guys it's almost like we start
managing them instead of coaching them
and the day that I got to just manage
I'm getting out but okay how much money
is there for basketball players at
Michigan State to divvy up
well there's no real set amount of money
if you want the truth at any of these
schools but I thought there was a
collective that would have like this is
the amount of money for the kids this
year there's no cap that's kind of
there's no cap so that's a problem
there's no cap and uh you know I
wouldn't say that we're spending a ton
of money on our players but I would say
that we're trying to take care of them
the best we can within the rules if
there are any rules anymore but you know
kids I mean you hear you hear the rumors
of the quarterbacks making eight million
and 3 million and guys making 500 that I
think there's a lot of rumors out there
that aren't right or hell you'd want to
be a basketball or football player again
if you can make that kind of money but
but like LeBron James's son
yep is gonna like what's he worth to a
university
well that's the other funny part you
know there's the collective and then
there's the uh a guy like LeBron James's
son what is he worth in the social media
world you know what well that I have no
idea because I hate the social media so
I don't pay any attention to it I don't
have it don't care about it don't want
to know about it you want the truth
are you recruiting LeBron James's son
you know we did recruit him a little bit
I uh I talked to LeBron about it at
Draymond Green's wedding if you want the
truth but I don't know and I'll come to
think of it I don't even know if I'm
gonna I'm allowed to tell you that
um
I might get fined or maybe they'll uh
maybe they'll suspend me from the NCAA
tournament so we'll just say that
there's a player out west that I looked
at you didn't say his name
yeah you did that's right yeah thank you
Dad you're good God I I got you know I
got Steve Kerr in trouble uh when he was
the GM of the sons
and I joked about hey you uh you
interested in signing LeBron at the time
and he goes yeah we'll give him the
mid-level exception or something and he
was joking David Stern didn't think it
was funny and he finds Steve I think uh
twenty five thousand dollars
um hey well it's great to talk to you
and uh have fun on Thursday night the
voice doesn't sound as bad as I thought
it was going to
no I'm doing good Dad I'm really uh
you're not yelling as much is that
what's going on
no I I I keep telling you every year
it's not the yelling I don't yell
anymore that's illegal now you'll get
lawyers that sue you for yelling at your
players you don't understand the new
rules Dan we just tell them would you
please guard somebody would you please
pass it to the right guy but what it is
in all honesty is when you lose sleep
you know do you ever lose sleep when you
don't sleep your voice goes okay have
you ever had parents say
I don't like the way you yell at my son
first
and what do you say
I said what would you do if you skip
class 15 times in a month
I never get a good answer either yeah
you want the truth
it's all good you know what and all
couldn't decide whatever the rules are
we'll abide by them but I hope we don't
lose a lot more good coaches because of
this because there's some really good
people that are trying to help kids and
uh there's some other people that are
trying to expose kids if you ask me and
we'll find a happy medium but right now
it's the NCAA tournament we're in the
sweet 16 I'm hoping I'm talking to you
next week because we're moving on how's
that good to talk to you coach thanks
for joining us thanks Dan that's Tom
Izzo Hall of Famer he's been at Michigan
State for 28 years